so this could very well be an exciting
video because we started this idea of a
fourier series that we could take a
periodic function and represent it as an
infinite sum of weighted cosines and
sines and we use that idea to say well
can we find formulas for those
coefficients and we were able to do that
using the powers of calculus and now we
can actually apply it for this
particular square wave and i picked a
square wave that has a period of 2 pi
and that's where actually a lot of these
two pies came out from and that's also
why we started here at cosine t and sine
of t they both have a frequency of one
over two pi which is the frequency of
our original square wave and then the
other terms have frequencies that are
multiples of that if we had a different
period then all of that would change but
i picked this period to just make the
math a little bit simpler and we will
generalize in the future but now let's
actually evaluate a sub 0 a sub n and b
sub n for this particular square wave
so the key to realize is that our square
wave between
0 and pi because we're going to keep
taking the definite integral from 0 to 2
pi from 0 to 2 pi from 0 to 2 pi the key
realization here is from 0 to pi
our function is equal to 3 and from pi
to 2 pi our function is equal to 0. so
all of these definite integrals
so this definite integral for example is
going to be the same thing as and i'll
do it once and then we'll see that trend
this is the same thing as 1 over 2 pi
times
the definite integral from
0 to pi of f of t dt plus the integral
from pi
to 2 pi of f of t
dt now f of t
between zero and pi we just said it's
equal to three and f of t between pi and
two pi well it's going to be equal to
zero and that's actually the case for
all for these other situations that f of
t is going to be 0 from pi to 2 pi and 0
times anything is going to be 0. so the
integrals the definite integrals over
this the second part of the interval are
always going to be 0.
and so it boils down to this and so
what's the definite integral from 0 to
pi of three dt
well this is going to be equal to
one over two pi
times
times so if you evaluate this
the anti-derivative three would be three
t evaluated from
from 0 to pi and so it would be 3 pi
minus 3 times 0 which is just 3 pi so
it's equal to 3 pi
over the 2 pi that we had already
over the 2 pi and so this is going to be
equal to 3 halves
three halves and that makes a lot of
sense because a sub zero we said you
could view that as the average value of
the function over that interval and the
average value of that function is indeed
if it's three half the time and zero the
other half of the time well then the
average is going to be one and a half or
three halves so that is our a sub zero
so now let's figure out the general a
sub n where n is not equal zero
so a sub n
well we are just going to take it's
going to be 1 over pi
1 over pi the definite integral i could
go from 0 to 2 pi but instead i'm just
going to cut to the chase i'm going to
go just from 0 to pi because the
integral from pi to 2 pi is just going
to be 0 because the function is equal to
0 it's going to be 0 times cosine t is
just going to be 0. so for this
particular square wave i can just worry
about from 0 to pi from 0 to pi f of t
is 3
so it's going to be 3 cosine nt
let me do that color three
cosine
of nt
cosine nt
dt
now what is this going to be equal to
well we can do a few things we could
take our 3 and bring it out front
so let me do that
so we could take that 3
and bring it out front so just putting
the 3 out here
so take that 3 put it out front and we
know that the derivative of sine of n t
is n cosine of n t so let's multiply the
inside and the out or let's multiply the
inside by n and then we could also
divide by n but we could put that
outside they would be
n divided by n we haven't changed the
value and so this is going to be equal
to
over n pi that's just what we had out
here
times
well the anti-derivative of this
business is going to be
sine of n t sine of n t
and we're going to evaluate from 0 to pi
so this is going to be equal to 3 over n
pi
times
sine of n pi well that's going to be 0
for any n minus sine of 0 times n well
that's going to be 0 for any n so all of
this is just going to be 0.
so a sub n is going to be equal to 0.
the coefficient on any for any
of a sub n's for any n not equals zero
it's going to be zero so actually we're
not we're not going to have any of these
cosines show up in the fourier expansion
let's think about our b sub n
when you look at the shape of the square
wave it actually makes a lot of sense
but let's now tackle our b sub n's
so our b sub n's get a little space here
so
b
sub n same thing we could take the we
could just worry about the interval from
0 to pi because from pi to 2 pi our f of
t is going to be equal to 0. so this is
going to be equal to
1 over pi
times the definite integral
once again i'm only going to worry about
from 0 to pi
0 to pi
d t
now the value of the function from 0 to
pi
is 3 we've seen that before i could put
it here but just to get a little bit
simpler let's just stick it right over
here so it's going to be 3 actually i
don't want to skip too many steps it's
going to be 3
times sine of n t
sine
of
n t
and let's see how can i reconstruct this
so it's easy to take the antiderivative
well this is going to be if we take that
3 out front it's going to be 3
over pi
and then you have your definite integral
from 0 to pi
of sine
of that same color
sine of n t
sine
of n t
dt
and we know the derivative of cosine n t
is negative n sine of n t so let's throw
a negative n
in here so negative n let's also divide
by negative n
just like that if you have negative n
divided by negative n we haven't changed
the value that's just 1. and so this is
going to be equal to negative 3 over n
pi
times
we're going to take the antiderivative
here so this is going to be cosine
of nt
evaluated
from 0
0 to pi
and so what is this this is going to be
equal to this is equal to negative 3
over n pi
cosine of 0n that's going to be 1 for
any n
minus
cosine
of oh sorry why did i start at 0. it's
going to be cosine of n pi cosine of n
pi
minus cosine of n times 0. so minus
cosine of 0 cosine of 0 is just going to
be 1 for any n
and so there you have it we have a
general and and you might say well
cosine of n pi is that positive 1 or is
that negative 1 well it depends if if n
is if n is even this is going to be
positive 1
if n is odd this is going to be negative
1. so it depends actually let's let's
just write that out so
b sub n
b
sub n is equal to
let's write those two cases so if n
is
if n is even
and another one if n is odd
so if n is even you're going to have
negative 3 over n pi
times actually let me just do it over
here so we have the space
so what would this thing evaluate to if
n is even so this n if it's even would
be like cosine of 2 pi cosine of 4 pi
cosine of 6 pi well in that situation
this is going to evaluate to 1 you're
going to have 1 minus 1 which is 0 so
the whole thing is going to evaluate to
0.
and if n is odd cosine of pi cosine of 3
pi cosine of
5 pi well those are going to evaluate to
negative 1 then it's going to be
negative 1 if n is odd negative 1 minus
1 is negative 2 and so this is all going
to be negative 2
negative 2 times negative 3 over n pi is
going to be 6
over
n
pi
so there you have it we have been able
to figure out our fourier expansion it
is going to be our square wave and we
definitely deserve a drum roll this is
many videos in the making
f of t
is going to be equal to a sub zero we
figured out in this video is equal to
three halves so it's going to be three
halves
let me write this well let me just write
it all in yellow so three halves now we
don't have any a sub n's we figure that
out all of the a sub n's are going to be
zero and then the b the only b sub n's
we have is when n is odd when n is odd
so
we're going to have b sub 1 so that's
going to be 6 over 1 pi
6 over 1 pi
sine
of 1 times t so sine of t
plus now we're not going to have a b sub
2 we're going to have a b sub 3
so 6
over 3 pi
times sine
of 3 t
and of course this is the same thing as
this is the same thing as
2 over pi times sine of 3t
plus
now we we're not going to have a b sub 4
we're going to have a b sub 5. so that's
going to be 6
over
pi
6 actually i liked i liked writing it
it's nicer to actually not simplify here
because you can see the pattern so it's
going to be plus
6 over 5 pi
times sine
of 5 t and we're just going to go on
and on and on and there you have it we
have our fourier expansion in the next
video we're actually going to visualize
this